cars have made life easier for billions
of people but can they do better can
they take on some routine car related
tasks in the future they may be able to
find a spot in a parking garage entirely
on their own VW presents V charge it
allows the driver to use an app to tell
an eagle to park itself the user enters
the time when they plan to return and if
desired a request that the car be
recharged the driver receives a
confirmation and leaves the car to
itself it does the rest automatically
does is dis local artists Irvine ho
Dyson hoofer believes this is the future
of driving you just leave the car at the
garage and go off to an appointment or
shopping and it finds a parking spot
automatically the real sensation is that
if a garage has a charging station the
car can automatically go to recharge
itself when it's fully charged it frees
up the station and finds another parking
spot south parking cars pose no danger
to other drivers or pedestrians cameras
ultrasound sensors and emergency braking
systems already developed for
conventional models have been adapted
for use in the V charge project the car
can recognize pedestrians and its path
and come to a stop
with V charge an electric car isn't
recharged in the usual way it parks
above an induction pad mounted in the
floor of the charging Bay
so I'm convene the entire charging
infrastructure is also far more
efficient once charging is complete the
car equipped with v charge automatically
makes way for another car to use the
station and finds another parking spot
the navigation system in the garage is
self-contained so a GPS signal is
unnecessary for the car to find its own
way around owner does GPS signal toughen
appendages all self parking cars will
eventually have to have access to
high-resolution 3d maps of the
participating garages to find their way
to the charging stations without GPS VW
calls its charging technology a smart
connect the storm I know Dyson /
explains that the charging station of
the future will work completely
independently of humans the car drives
itself in and a robot arm makes the
connection it takes 19 to 30 minutes to
reach eighty percent of the battery
capacity which the car need text by
itself and automatically makes the
station available or the robot can move
to another car but why do we need a
robot arm at all the high voltages
require thick cables which are heavy and
inflexible they may be too cumbersome
for some people to handle but the robot
arm has no problem with it and the
driver can go shopping or have a cup of
tea in the meantime
once the robot has accessed the car's
data it can locate the connector and
plug in the charging cable without human
help a camera and a light help it to
target the socket with millimeter
precision but the robot can't open the
recharging cap itself there are too many
variations of shape and position for it
to remember either the driver will have
to open the cap before handing over the
car or when the time comes you will have
to open itself electronically
you